[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique berthet france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine et
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec lydia
guirous ce essayiste et candidates les
républicains aux municipales face à vous
jean paul huchon président honoraire du
conseil régional d'île de france
invité sur ce plateau également sergio
coronado soutien et les filles candidat
à la mairie de bangui et xavier bois
président du syndicat autonome des
sapeurs-pompiers merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france et c'est à la une cette
semaine regarder de nouvelles violences
entre pompiers et policiers mardi des
images qui avaient déjà suscité
l'indignation en octobre dernier mais
cette fois ci la mobilisation at-elle
payé on va en parler après les
concessions annoncées par le ministère
de l'intérieur les syndicats ont annoncé
la suspension de leur mobilisation
des soldats du feu qui dénoncent aussi
les agressions dont ils sont de plus en
plus victime dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions une insécurité à la hausse en
france confirmée par les dernières
statistiques ministériels de la sécurité
intérieure
on est parvenu comme m² au niveau
salaire on est des fois payer moins cher
qu'un carrie peur que mes joueurs et
c'est ça qui on n'a rien contre eux au
contraire ils le méritent leur salaire
mais nous on est très risqué notre vie
pour tout le monde pour tout le monde
même pour les gens qui nous agressent
quand on se fait agresser dans la rue
quand on se fait agresser sur
intervention
si ces gens là étaient en prime dans un
peu on serait même prêt à donner notre
vie pour et c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'on gomme expliquer tout ça use mais
le problème c'est qu'on n'est pas
entendue donc enchères sont absolument à
recouvrir un politique qui un jour
commence à nous dépend qui reconnaît ce
spécialiste qui nous prennent en compte
ce que tous les gouvernements successifs
depuis des années de suivre un peu plus
de content qu'ils nous négligeons m j'ai
proposé une augmentation de la prime au
feu qui semble satisfaire les
organisations syndicales qui on regrette
quelques violences qui ont eu lieu dans
le déroulement de la manifestation
pendant que nous étions en train
d'inspecter xavier bois vous étiez ou
pas peut-être à cette manifestation
mardi en tout cas le ministre a fait les
concessions dit il
une augmentation de la prime du feu
notamment alors oui j'étais à la
manifestation enfin j'étais en rendez
vous avec le ministre justement donc on
a en effet demandé un rendez vous à être
reçus avant la mutualisation pour
pouvoir se soit apaisée soit annoncée en
fonction de 10 à lens qu'il n'aurait pu
être fait le matin le planning de
l'agenda ne l'a pas permis donc c'est
dommage et concomitants voilà c'était un
petit peu que la dernière fois aussi on
avait demandé un rendez-vous à wanda ont
été reçus pendant le déroulement des
manifestations donc on n'est pas là pour
encadrer nos hommes
faire respecter les parcours ou comme ça
donc c'est un petit peu vous avez
préféré que ça se fasse en deux temps si
on avait été reçu avant on aurait pu
expliquer nos collègues prend des
décisions ensemble au lieu de faire en
même temps sous la pression de la
manifestation qui se déroule veut pas
forcément bien parce que dès le début il
ya eu des incidents en tête de cortège
donc on l'apprend ça fait dix minutes
qu'on est ainsi avec le ministre on va
parler des de ce que vous avez réussi à
obtenir les diables rouges 100 corps ces
images de violence entre pompiers et
policiers
qu'est ce que ça donne comme comme
message en tout cas de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en france est décédé images
qui sont terribles normalement la police
et les pompiers sont main dans la main
c'est des personnes qui quand même c'est
un sas quasiment un sacerdoce que d'être
policiers ou pompiers qui sont prêts à
risquer leur vie pour pour pour sauver
la nôtre et nous protéger et les voir
ces images là je trouve que ça fait mal
à la france et à la république sadi la
tension sociale qui en france a dit
aussi les difficultés que rencontrent
les pompiers mais même mais même les
policiers le manque de reconnaissance le
manque de moyens peut-être des salaires
qui sont pas à la hauteur de leurs de
leurs engagements et et c'est terrible
d'en arriver à cette situation où ces
gens qui sont prêts quasiment à tout
pour pour nous protéger pour notre
sécurité arrive à être comme ça en
conflit c'est dramatique de jean paul
huchon votre réaction aussi à ces images
de nouveau des images vivantes entre ici
et qu'on pille les pompiers je pense que
c'est la catégorie la plus populaire en
france parce que c'est quand même
en effet des gens qui risquent leur vie
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles et avec un statut qui n'a pas
été revalorisé depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années c'est mon héros on n'est pas
c'est pas dans l'immédiat
mais policiers sont souvent appelés pour
protéger ce qui est en banlieue quand il
ya des immeubles texte aidera les
policiers protègent aussi les bons là ce
que je comprends pas c'est comment le
ministère de l'intérieur a pu laisser
des policiers vont matraquer parce qu'on
voit bien les images c'est quand même
hallucinant des pompiers c'est quelque
chose qui est nouveau mais parce que ça
je n'ai jamais vu ça comme ça avant et
je pense que c'est tout à fait
inadmissible dans l'opinion publique ça
pèsera très lourd parce que c'est
symboliquement toujours ceux qui sont
les plus proches des gens et les plus
populaires s'agit des infirmières des
instituteurs des policiers des pompiers
qui sont oubliés et parfois matraquer
dans quelque chose qui vraiment ne doit
pas et qui conclut cette séquence qui
n'est pas encore fini loin de là de
manière très adulte est détestable votre
réaction sergio coronado cette violence
que l'on que l'on voit quasiment
systématiquement maintenant l'heure des
manifestations y compris celle des
pompiers
je suis assez d'accord avec jean paul
huchon et j'aurai la tentation de
qualifier cette violence parce que quand
vous nous dites c'est des images d'une
lance moi ce que je vois depuis un
certain temps pour dire les choses très
clairement depuis le départ depuis
l'origine du moins des jaunes ski
ce qui s opèrent dans le pays c'est une
très grande impression face au mouvement
social en fait faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont peu importe la
catégorie de population qui se
retrouvent dans la rue pour protester
pour réclamer de meilleures conditions
de travail des augmentations de salaire
ou pour refuser les réformes que ce
gouvernement porte on a régulièrement
ces mêmes images de matraquage je
rappelle quand même que la france a été
rappelé à l'ordre par des instances
internationales
mais chez le battle et que jean paul
huchon connaît bien que je le connais
bien pour avoir été parlementaire des
français de l'étranger au moment où il a
été réélu président du chili et qui
dirige désormais
le haut commissariat des droits humains
avait rappelé la france en fait à une
meilleure utilisation de la force
légitime et à les alerter sur la
disproportion en fait de la répression
donc moi je suis choquée comme beaucoup
de français de voir que finalement même
con ce sont des pompiers des héros dans
l'imaginaire collectif
ils ont droit toujours à la même réponse
la matraque de la part de ce
gouvernement et c'est inquiétant c'est
incapacité finalement à organiser le
dialogue social avec l'ensemble des
catégories aujourd'hui mobilisés je
rappelle ce que vous disiez sur cette
manière d'organiser le désordre c'est à
dire qu'au lieu de vous permettre
d'encadrer la manifestation dont vous
qu'on vaut en même temps il y avait ce
soir une réunion qui était prévue avec
les avocats avant la grande mobilisation
nationale de demain est en fait le
ministère a décidé finalement de voir
comment la manifestation se passer pour
voir s'il pouvait prendre appui sur des
images de violence pour dénoncer les
remercions attend de voir ce qui se
passe avant de prendre avant de
dialoguer alors que je pense que dans
une bonne politique cantonnée en
responsabilité c'est fou
favoriser de privilégier dans tous les
cas de figure le dialogue
l'acompte la concertation et d'éviter
qu'on c'est possible parce que des fois
ce n'est pas possible
les affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre en tout cas je crois
que c'est une façon de faire
dt ce talent ça met en danger les forces
de l'ordre on connaît les situations des
forces de l'ordre et des dizaines de
millions d'heures supplémentaires non
payées 24 millions d'heures
supplémentaires non payées c'est les
conditions de travail dramatiques
parfois dans certains quartiers et puis
c'est que le gouvernement s'est engagé à
payer jusqu'à un certain seuil
oui enfin les engagements moi je vous
savez pour un syndicaliste ce soit à la
fin du mois sur une fiche je pète et
puis d'autre part également l'image des
forces de l'ordre qui s'est
considérablement dégradée il ya toute
une série d' enquête aujourd'hui dans
les manèges gipn
on a qualifié les dérapages de violence
policière les policiers qui étaient
extrêmement populaire c'est une
corporation dont on a besoin était
redevenue populaire devenue populaire et
notamment
qui sont aujourd'hui visibles mais qui
sont aujourd'hui dans l'oeil du cyclone
à cause de la doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre que ce gouvernement a choisi
dans tous les cas de figure je pense que
le pays ne va pas très bien et le
premier responsable de cette situation
c'est évidemment le gouvernement alors
qu'ils savent castaner s'est félicité de
la suspension de la mobilisation des
pompiers c'est par le dialogue jamais
par la violence que nous avons soit
ensemble avec les collectivités locales
il a tweeté christophe castaner à
l'issue de cette manifestation s'apprête
un peu à sourire c'est par le dialogue
jamais par la violence ça ça tranche un
petit peu avec les images qu'on a vu
dans la rue à ce moment là vous êtes
d'accord avec le ministre moyennement je
reviens et vous avez très bien décrit la
situation en fait nous conte ce qu'ont
dénoncé la stratégie de maintien de
l'ordre comme avant on note c'est pas la
première fois que les pompiers
manifestent à paris
bien sûr là le pour que la tête de
cortège soient matraqués et gaz et
conviennent retirer un petit camion de
pompier qui vit qui vient faire du bruit
ça s'est jamais vu c'est inédit en avait
les un cordon de forces de l'ordre qui
nous empêchait d'avancer qu'ils
maintenaient enfin vous regardez moi
j'ai vu les vidéos parce que comme je
n'ai pas pu la série face à sion dans
l'été contenu en était contenu donc pas
forcément il ya un malaise social dans
le pays
notre corporation dont nous sommes en
souffrance parce qu on est surchargé de
travail de missions qu'on ne devrait pas
faire donc the ministry dit que on
dialogue
ben on avait largement le temps de
dialoguer de négocier avant cette
manifestation
et comme vous l'avez très bien dit on
fait en sorte que la mutation se
produise il y aura forcément des
incidents soit qu'on va provoquer
souvent certains pompiers pour être allé
faire un petit peu de zèle sur le périph
au cou la déveine la dernière fois à
l'assemblée nationale ont fait de la
violence est comme ça à prendre par le
plus du fonds aujourd'hui les
revendications des sapeurs pompiers
c'est un problème de france après une
société note de service de secours est
malade mais vraiment malade on perd du
sens à réaliser
à faire notre métier on essaie de
location bien sûr on a envie de faire ce
métier on va regarder vos revendications
justement le droit à partir à la
retraite à 57 ans sans décote
la revalorisation de la prime du feu qui
stagne maintenant depuis 1990 elle est
une hausse des effectifs et des mesures
concrètes pour lutter contre les
agressions de toutes ces revendications
xavier bois qu'est lesquels avec vous
obtenu alors on a obtenu des engagements
mais comme vous l'avez très bien dit les
engagements ces marins voilà qu'on verra
dans le temps donc on est conscient par
contre que les problèmes que l'on nous
dénonçons sont les poèmes qu'ils sont
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et c'est pas des
problèmes qu'on va résoudre du jour au
lendemain la sur-sollicitation sur les
interventions de secours à victimes
aujourd'hui il faut des moyens il faut
des vecteurs de transport pour des gens
qui ne peuvent plus visite est revisité
par un médecin parce qu'il ya plus de
médecins
voilà en fait ses côtés d'autres qu'il
veut aller parce qu'il a mal au ventre
depuis trois jours et ben on appelle les
pompiers quelqu'un qui aime on a des
tickets de d'intervention mais c'est des
violences conjugales en violence
conjugale ans et des pompiers qui y vont
parce qu'il ya plus l'effort d'être le
dernier ressort pour ces populations qui
souffrent bien sûr mais alors c'est un
petit peu le sens de notre métier ou
d'apporter du réconfort
sauf que aujourd'hui on fait ça à
longueur de temps les conséquences de
faire ça à longueur de temps c'est que
quand on est en garde à la caserne condé
normalement on devrait s'entraîner là on
ne peut plus le faire donc nos maintien
des acquis techniques on en train de le
perdre aujourd'hui et le pompier se
rencontre on voit ça de l'intérieur et
c'est ce qui nous fait mal en fait
aujourd'hui donc autant on va dans
manifester en comme l'a dit le collègue
à la manifestation place de la
république
il faudrait qu'ils aient un politique
qui s'occupe un peu nous nous écoute on
revendique pas des hausses de salaires
uniquement
écoutez nous prenions conscience et
d'associations qui dure vous dit sergio
coronado la précédente
c'est très inquiétant c'est tous les
corps de métiers qui ont pour mission en
fait de venir en aide à nos concitoyens
les pompiers les policiers
je les dix le nombre de suicides depuis
l'analyse du récent mais également tous
les corps hospitalier
mais les médecins les infirmières les
aides-soignants sont mobilisés depuis
des mois et des mois dans le pays
on a eu des grèves des urgences on a eu
jusqu'à 266 service des urgences en
grève le même jour qu'on a eu des
démissions massives des chefs de service
et dont il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas de bien ça ne date pas d'hier c'est
vrai et ce ne sera pas réglé du jour au
lendemain cependant organiser la
concertation reconnaître les difficultés
l'effort budgétaire que le pays doit
consentir pour que ces corps de métiers
puissent continuer à s'occuper de la
population et de nos concitoyens c'est
la moindre des choses c'est une base de
départ on a l'impression que depuis le
départ
le gouvernement joue avec le feu sans
mauvais jeu de mots avec les pompiers
mais avec tous les autres corps de
métier mobiliser c'est à dire préféré la
violence panda partie de la population
des gens vous voyez c'est des violences
et des nervis on a vu ce que ça a donné
avec les gilet jaune gouvernement était
néanmoins contraint une fine et de
lâcher 11 milliards 17 11 euros début et
17 à l'arrivée sans satisfaire les
revendications qui avait été clairement
formulée par ce mouvement bien sûr alors
il faudrait une politique plus
volontariste selon vous jean paul huchon
justement pour régler tous ces métiers
qui sont en confrontation directe avec
une urgence sociale savez on réfléchit
toujours pour savoir ce que doit faire
l'êta je dois faire les collectivités
locales existera donc il ya le régalien
et c'est le régalien qui souffrent
régalien qui souffrent le plus
aujourd'hui
et en plus on obligé collectivités
locales à suivre dans une certaine
mesure puisque dans les départements
c'est les pompiers qui sont en charge
les départements en charge des pommiers
plus généralement il ya eu cette semaine
une information lourde qui est
l'accusation portée contre la france
pour la manière de lire ses prisons et
donc si vous avez une réputation siens
vous avez une réputation de la france
sur l'ensemble des questions qui
concernent directement la vie des
citoyens qui commence à être mauvaise
il ya des européens nous
amis des pays étrangers sont très
inquiet par sucre ils ont un patient qu'
il ya une dérive française de l'autorité
est là pour voir aujourd'hui et c'est
symboliser évidemment son autorité mais
qui règlent pas les problèmes de ce sont
les fonctions régaliennes de l'état
les fonctions là ils sont affaiblis
depuis des dizaines d'années par des
villes des politiques budgétaires des
politiques de diminution de l'apij
agence publique et de manière
concomitante à quoi on assiste
on le voit au moment des élections
municipales parce que c'est au coeur du
débat public c'est d'airé structuration
d'hôpitaux ces dérives structuration de
service moi je vais dans une ville par
exemple où on a un hôpital qui va de
fait quasiment disparaître en fait et
donc avec une sorte de désert médical
qui s'instaure avec une difficulté à
avoir accès aux spécialistes
et quand on se trouve en difficulté que
fait-on bas vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure lors de votre intervention
appelle les pompiers
donc vos clients sur des tâches qui ne
sont pas a priori les tâches
prioritaires de votre corps de métier
qui est plutôt de s'attaquer au feu pour
sécuriser les périmètres et donc c'est
une réalité que le pays connaît depuis
des dizaines d'années on est à l'os on
est vraiment à l'os c'est à dire que si
on ne se dit pas quel est le contrat
social sur lequel dans les années qui
viennent ce pays
la vivre avec les services publics les
services régaliens
et puis la population parce que ce qui
fait le contrat français c'est d'avoir
accès à l'éducation à la sécurité grâce
aux pompiers pour policiers à la santé
grâce aux hôpitaux aux hôpitaux publics
à un moment donné je crois que les
choses deviennent extrêmement compliqué
et il est normal naturel parfois que les
gens éprouvent de la frustration est
manifeste de la colère démantèlement de
cette protection la haye lors de la
colère qui s'ajoute à la colère puisque
les chiffres de la criminalité sont
sortis en descendent ils ne sont pas
bons 960
10 homicide constaté en 2009 76 morts de
plus qu'en 2018
avec 120 signalements de violences par
mois des violences contre les pompiers
spécifiquement c'est cette violence
aussi qui fait que vous êtes débordé
aujourd'hui xavier bois la violence je
voudrais aussi repart qu'on reparle sur
le l'indemnité de feu soir ils engagent
mais sur la violence on arrive à des
chiffres qui avoisine les dix agressions
de sapeurs-pompiers par jour en france
encore une fois la question qu'on doit
se poser c'est pourquoi on est agressée
elle à perdre ce que vous secours et
bien sûr mais aussi de la part de
personnes qui vont le temps des
guets-apens la dure
alors voilà il ya plusieurs niveaux de
violence il ya des gens qui peuvent être
violents de par une pathologie des gens
qui peuvent être violents ma part
soudain on arrête on n'a pas à
intervenir sur ces gens-là ça c'est des
forces de l'ordre qui doit intervenir je
vous prends le cas d'une ivresse voie
publique ivresse publique manifeste est
prévue par le code de la santé publique
c'est les policiers qui doivent
intervenir ce ne sont pas les pompiers
mais sauf que comme il n'ya pas de
véhicule de police il ya pas quand elle
est vécue la police et qui a pu de
places censé de dégrisement on envoie
les pompiers et qu'est-ce que les
pompiers font ce qu'on appelle un
conflit de valeurs on entend déjà on
sait que c'est pas notre mission et en
plus de ça on va surcharger
on participe à la montée en charge des
hôpitaux français que nos collègues aux
urgences on va leur ramener encore
quelqu'un qui n'a rien à y faire
qui n'est pas malade qui n'est pas
blessé mais qui peuvent être en charge
et qui peut et qui trouble l'ordre
public
donc voilà les missions de pompiers ou
est-ce qu'on en ait grande manifestation
d'ailleurs à strasbourg la semaine
dernière justement contre ces violences
contre votre profession lydia guirous ce
c'est un phénomène qui prend de
l'ampleur
la violence contre les pompiers et la
violence en jeu de manière générale oui
il ya 700 agressions par jour maintenant
en france il ya une augmentation de 8 %
quand même des des coups et blessures
depuis un an + 21% depuis trois ans il
ya + 19 % de viol quand même en une
année en france donc oui il ya en plus
ya par ailleurs les cambriolages qui ont
qui ont explosé donc il ya un climat de
violence qui c'est qui s'est installée
ce qu'on voit ce qui est une forme de
debès de recul de l'autorité une
autorité qui est pas incarner l'un
explique l'autre
je pense oui parce que d'ailleurs les
policiers qui souffrent également qu'ils
ont très peu d'équipements dans le
budget de cette année il ya une baisse
de 6% du budget qui alloue à
l'équipement des forces de l'ordre alors
qu'ils demandent en même temps d'avoir
plus plus de moyens pour pour s'équiper
pour pouvoir s'entraîner à voir des
voitures des gilets pare-balles qui
fonctionne et on leur retire des moyens
donc je pense que tout ça est lié et
puis par ap
et puis quand tu es policiers arrêtent
les personnes souvent il n'ya pas les
condamnations qui suivent les jours il
ya eu du mal à former un virus tration
la justice ne suit pas on parlait des
prisons tout à l'heure emmanuel macron
avait une promesse de campagne
construire je crois 40000 places de
prison il a divisé le chiffre par trois
voilà on ne construit plus de prisons
des prisons sont saturés il est
indispensable de construire des prisons
malheureusement la violence explose
il faut construire des prisons et là on
a l'impression qu'il ya une politique
pénale qui consiste à dire bon bain
jusqu'à 6 mois vous n'allez pas en
prison c'est pas très grave si vous êtes
condamnés à 6 mois
c'est ce qu'avait dit nicolas nicolas
nicole belloubet et concernant la
violence elle s'exprime chez les
pompiers dans certains quartiers qui
sont devenues des zones où on n'a plus
le droit d'aller où vous avez des
groupes comme comme des gangs aux états
unis qui considèrent que c'est leur
territoire les forces de l'ordre les
pompiers mais même parfois les médecins
n'ont pas le droit de s'y rend et vous
avez des agressions de pompiers vous
avez des agressions de policiers au mois
de novembre à chanteloup les vignes en
ile de france
et là vous avez un premier ministre qui
dit c'est une bande d'imbéciles et
responsable
non c'est une bande de délinquants qui
s'en prend aux forces de l'ordre qui se
retrouvent attaquer et et qui ne sont
pas soutenues par par le premier
ministre leur sergio coronado et ensuite
vous jean paul huchon sur ces violences
justement c'est la priorité
l'insécurité la priorité numéro un pour
les français qui vont voter oui
malheureusement
une augmentation des faits de violence
des faits d'agression des actes racistes
antisémites
les chiffres sont en effet inquiétant
moi je ne peins je ne pense pas
néanmoins que la présence de l'état se
résume à une présence policière
je crois que dans des territoires qui
sont difficiles parfois ce que l'on
constate avant que leur violence et leur
tour de la police municipale avant que
la violence n'explose c'est finalement
olemps la démission progressive des des
services publics des services régaliens
de l'état
on voit qu'il n'ya plus de politique de
la ville il n'y a pas de politique
d'animation pas de politique d'insertion
et puis pour avoir suivi les questions
de police et de justice pendant très
longtemps pendant mon mandat de
parlementaire je pense qu'il faut pas
avoir d' approche simpliste la prison
c'est une machine à récidive
on le sait depuis fort longtemps et qui
ont construit excusez moi je vous ai pas
interrompu les ans qu'on soit plus on
construit plus on construit de places de
prison puis on incarcère en france et
donc on est régulièrement condamnée en
raison des chiffres de surpopulation
je crois en effet que chaque délit et
chaque crime doit faire l'objet d'une
sanction et d'une punition néo moi je ne
pense pas qu'on règle les questions de
sécurité les questions de troubles à
l'ordre public
les questions de désordre uniquement par
la caste répressive skis ce qui manque
depuis des dizaines d'années ça a été le
cas au début des années 80 par exemple
quand on avait une vraie réflexion sur
la politique de la ville sur la
politique d'insertion sur la politique
d'accompagnement
je crois je crois que vous même vous ne
voulez pas entendre madame ne voulait
pas entendre madame vous ne voulez pas
entendre madame parce que la police
on est donc je pense que j'avais face à
moi je ne hurle pas mal à garder mais
souriant nous parler par entendre c'est
que en france comme partout ailleurs la
prison ça produit de la récidive ça
produit des délinquances a produit de la
violence quand les gens sortent et qui
ne sont pas accompagnés donc la solution
que vous donnez et paraît simple et par
est alléchante mais le résultat à la fin
c'est des territoires encore plus soumis
à la dangerosité des trafiquants des
violents des voleurs des gens qui ne
respectent pas l'ordre d'exercer sa
hotte solution celui des soins d'autres
solutions ont versé des millions dans la
policière je vais pour la loi et la
violence y avoir changé et rien de moins
elle a changé de nature on est violent
plus jeunes par exemple on n'est plus
seulement d'intention et violent à
l'égard des représentants de l'état ce
qui n'était pas nécessaire la semaine
violence sociale mais sociétal dit le
criminologue alain bauer justement dans
ses conclusions sur cette augmentation
de la violence aujourd'hui oui donc mais
a changé la réflexion sur la manière
dont on s'attaque à la violence elle ne
fait pas aujourd'hui objet d'une
réflexion finalement politique qu'au
niveau cela devrait être le cas
je crois en effet que la réponse
sécuritaire ne pas être la seule
ça ne veut pas dire que moi je suis de
ceux qui pensent qu'il ne faut jamais pu
n'iront jamais sanctionnés non mais
qu'il faut s'attarder sur les résultats
aujourd'hui de la politique pénale de la
politique répressive du fait que par
exemple les les institutions qui sont
chargés de la prévention n'ont pas les
moyens d'assurer cette mission et celles
et ceux qui vous propose simplement la
prison comme seule solution vous montent
parce que le résultat on le connaît
rapidement depuis trois ans à une forme
de laxisme dans la continuité à du
quinquennat de de françois hollande
et les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes avec
avec ce rapport qui a été publié dans le
jdd + 21 % en trois ans on a été plutôt
laxiste on a été contre la construction
de prison contre le fait de condamner
les personnes
les résultats sont là la violence
augmente en france la diminution est
toujours de policiers excusez maintenant
nommer une remarque plus grande est la
plus grande diminution de force de paul
enfin la plus grande diminution de
forces de l'ordre de policiers dans nos
rues c'est sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy qui vous avez soutenu
par les gens de chez nous je voudrais
plein pointe est quelque chose de très
simple il y a aujourd'hui depuis les
gilets jaunes utilisation à déploiement
des forces de police qui fait qu'il n'y
a plus de forces de police pour exercer
le travail ordinaire et ça personne ne
le dit personne ne le voit alors qu' il
ya des politiques qui pourraient être
dans un travail de contact avec la
population extradé dans la police de
proximité mais tout ça est abandonnée et
skate abandonner aussi et ça c'est très
grave
c'est tout ce qui est le travail de
prévention les clubs de prévention les
les types qui prennent en charge les
gosses dans les quartiers moi j'étais
président d'un club de prévention
ça a donné quand même des résultats on
pouvait s'occuper des gosses quand il
était en difficulté et cetera en tout ça
tout ça a disparu dans le cette rigueur
budgétaire qui s'applique et qu'on
continue à nous proposer en disant on va
supprimer des non fonctionnaires ça ne
va pas merci rester avec nous on
continue ce débat sur la grogne sociale
en france après la manifestation d'une
confié mardi
8e journée nationale
interprofessionnelle mercredi alors que
la réforme des retraites a commencé son
parcours législatif et financiers cette
semaine on en parle dans quelques
minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
cet accord c'est un accord politique
ça va bien au delà d'une simple guerre
commerciale
il est clair que la chine avec un
beaucoup plus à perdre que les états
unis je suis pas convaincu tout de même
que le jeu ne soit pas les équilibres et
qui nie pas vous avez un certain nombre
de secteurs d'activité aux états unis
qui ont été lourdement impactés
s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont en train de
perdre leur statut de superpuissance et
unique superpuissance en la chine est un
pays qui peut beaucoup plus rapidement
que n'importe quel autre pays du monde
se passer des états unis et entraîné
avec elle en plus un certain nombre
d'autres pays européens que c'est
aujourd'hui la chine qui remet en cause
l'hégémonie américaine
[Musique]
et l'actualité c'est évidemment le
corona virus là aussi c'est un peu un
effet de la mondialisation
mon ami quand même plus d'un mois avant
que l'information remonte de ou ham
jusqu'à pékin dire que les premiers cas
du coronavirus remonte au mois de
novembre dans les effets économiques
commencent à se faire sentir et ils vont
se faire sortir notamment en france où
des touristes non mais il ya eu quand
même des mesures très autoritaire de
président
bien sûr mais pour pouvoir stopper la
contagion il n'y a que des mesures
autoritaires qui peuvent être prises sk
pas un message là en direction de trumpf
c'est constant chez les chinois depuis
toujours un
c'est nous avons réussi en 30 ans à nous
développer à un niveau vous ai mis deux
cents ans à le faire alors venez pas
nous donner des leçons alors là escapade
là aussi une autre leçon c'est que la
mondialisation dont on a dit que pis que
pendre
on n'est pas très bien outillé c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand une épidémie vient
de chine
bah elle se répand dans le monde entier
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec nos
contributeurs lydia guirous ce jean paul
huchon et nos invités sergio coronado
soutien et les filles et candidat à la
mairie de bondy et xavier bois président
du syndicat autonome des sapeurs
pompiers
la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites se poursuit dans la rue alors
que le texte a commencé son parcours
législatif cette semaine et que s'est
ouvert jeudi la conférence sur le
financement
un timing très serré et contesté par
l'opposition mardi le sénat a demandé
aux premiers ministres de lever la
procédure accélérée
réponse le lendemain d'edouard philippe
nous allons rester sur le calendrier
proposé
[Musique]
la conférence des présidents qui vient
de se réunir a décidé de s'opposer à
l'engagement de la procédure accélérée
sur le projet de loi organique relative
au système universel de retraite et sur
le projet de loi instituant un système
universel de retraite
cette décision sera notifiée à monsieur
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
été donnée de cette communication
nous allons tenir le calendrier que nous
nous sommes fixés monsieur le président
marseille et le calendrier que nous
avons fixée c'est effectivement la
présentation d'un projet de loi en
conseil des ministres c'était vendredi
dernier et l'examen par l'assemblée
nationale puis par le sénat au cours du
premier semestre de ce texte de façon à
ce que nous puissions espérer
je ne veux pas préjuger de l'issue du
débat parlementaire mais c'est en tout
cas l'objectif que nous nous fixons une
adoption du texte avant l'interruption
estivale voilà avant l'interruption
estivale les choses doivent être réglées
jean paul huchon c'est une négociation
au pas de course n'a qui s'engagent au
niveau législatif
oui mais je pense que le point ministre
s'avance bourdy lee qui devra tenir son
calendrier parce que il y a des
syndicats il ya des parlementaires et on
peut pas effacer d'un seul coup la
protestation d'une des deux institutions
majeures de
de notre démocratie qui est le sénat et
je fait que sa façon on n'a que quatre
le fait que ça soit assouline qui est
inférieur socialiste qui qui parle au
nom du sénat devrait quand même un petit
peu remué les méninges de nos
gouvernants halal à l'unanimité de la
conférence exactement donc il ya quand
même c'est fait tous les feux sont au
rouge mais le gouvernement veut
néanmoins s'en tire le mieux la france
et bien sûr mais c'est une
c'est quelque chose qui va se terminer
pas bien parce qu'on ne peut pas espérer
que c'est très fort si on veut que cette
réforme est est un sens c'est qu'elle
sera quand même pas rejetées par une
grande majorité des français et des
forces politiques ça c'est pas comme ça
qu'on gère un pays
xavier bois on a entendu le ministre de
l'intérieur dire que vous alliez à vous
aviez obtenu une revalorisation de la
prime du feu d'autres concessions ont
été faites aussi suite à la mobilisation
alors donc je vous ai peur les
engagements donc on a eu des
désengagements comme quoi il y avait les
dossiers avaient été pris en compte
ils disent allait se régler donc on sait
que le calendrier va être long quand il
y en a on a accordé la revalorisation
l'indemnité de feu aujourd'hui qu'il ya
dix neuf depuis 1990 ont demandé à ce
qu'elle soit 1,28 porté à 28 comme entre
les forces nordistes 28 % du traitement
donc c'est variable en fonction du grade
et non pas en fonction du métier qu'on
exécute 28 % du traitement cet hymne
demande qu'on avait estimé légitime
comme pour les autres forces votre
public et nous propose une augmentation
à 25%
donc nous on aurait préféré négocier
avec nos employeurs ce qui paye parce
que ordonné une augmentation alors que
ce n'est pas lui qui paye c'est un petit
peu délicat d'autant plus qu'aux
lendemains qui sont vos employeurs pour
nous téléspectateurs rennes les
employeurs sont les présidents des
conseils départementaux
voilà donc le ce que disait je suis tout
à l'heure les pompiers on a un système
bicéphale en est commandée par le
régalien l'état pour tout ce qui est des
missions est financé par les
collectivités locales donc le président
des contres les conseils départementaux
et c'est eux qui financent donc
aujourd'hui on s'est retrouvé sur une
partie de ping pong où les employeurs
disent
on considère votre demande est légitime
si j'avais l'argent de l'état je voulais
accorderait et l'état dit c'est tout à
fait normal je ne suis pas votre
employeur sinon comme dans la police
dans la police je lui ai accordé mais je
suis leur employeur quand le ministre
castaner nous nous raconte et à nous
peut pas de me dire parce que ce n'est
pas notre employeur donc aujourd'hui il
veut imposer une augmentation à 25% de
l'unité de feu aux conseils
départementaux on sait très bien que la
libre administration des collectivités
permettra au département de pouvoir
accorder cette prime en fonction d'un
calendrier ce que nous rejetions et
c'est pas lui qui paye donc l'état doit
quand on entendait le président sarkozy
à l'époque un congrès de
sapeurs-pompiers dire la reconnaissance
de la nation on vous la doa messieurs
quand il s'adresse aux pompiers voilà on
a envie de dire s'il ya une
reconnaissance de la nation que l'on
nous doit
l'état doit donner les moyens aux
collectivités de nous accorder ce que
l'on demande en moyens en effectif
l'indemnité de feu c'était quelque chose
qu'on pouvait obtenir qui aurait apaisé
les situations et faire comprendre un
petit peu à tout le monde que notre
métier va mal et que les problèmes - un
peu long à régime santé vous n'êtes pas
entendu on a entendu de secrétaire
d'état à la fonction publique aussi dire
que de toute façon
vous alliez pouvoir partir cinq à dix
ans plus tôt c'est ce que vous vouliez
également et on écoute le secrétaire
d'état on en parle après les gens
d'aller policiers pardon les douaniers
la branche surveillance les pompiers
professionnels
les surveillants pénitentiaires les
policiers municipaux et les contrôleurs
aériens
puisque les contrôleurs aériens font
l'objet d'une directive spécifique
européenne bénéficieront toujours d'un
départ anticipé soit 2,5 soit de 10 ans
avant l'âge légal d'ouverture des droits
la loi prévoit ce départ anticipé pour
les métiers considérés comme dangereux
et un décret comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui précisera profession par
profession les conditions de ce départ
anticipé
enfin vous donc ce sera cinq ans plus
tôt il faut soit validé aussi par lui on
l'a déjà en fait ce départ anticipé nous
n'avons on peut quitter la profession à
taux plein à 57 ans lorsqu'on a réuni
toutes les conditions
la nuitée ou pour le moment c'est comme
ça demain nous dire qu'on partira à 57
parce que faut pas faire de 10 ans et
pas pour les pompiers c'est pour les
policiers donc 57 ans pourra partir à 57
ans avec une décote de 5% par rapport à
la pivot d' équilibre qui est sera de 59
pour nous si on fait le para liste
indépendante avec le droit commun et qui
augmentera de toute façon qui augmentera
parce que quand on regarde comment il va
être mis en place c'est par rapport à
l'espérance de vie donc il va faire que
d'augmenter c'est un non-sens vous
départ anticipé pour les métiers comme
les nôtres si on nous dit à un moment
qu'on ne peut plus partir en
intervention parce qu'on est trop vieux
il n'y a pas si on est trop vieux
aujourd'hui on sera encore trop vieux
demain comme on était trop vieux hier il
ya les revendications dianou 25 ou 30
ans peut-être où les pompiers demandent
un départ à la retraite à 50 ans on nous
la grande et à 55,55 est devenu 57 et
demain ça sera quoi déjà pour partir à
taux plein il faudra attendre cinq ans
c'est un peu le problème pour tous les
français annoncée très fermé des
retraites
sergio coronado comment est-ce que vous
jugez cette gestion de à la va vite en
tout cas on le voit le gouvernement qui
veut coûte que coûte que ce les choses
soient bouclées à l'été d'abord à 100
que c'est moins d'amateurisme
je crois partagée par tous les
observateurs devant les imprécisions
la méconnaissance d'ailleurs de
cellectis qui sont chargés de dents de
vendre la réforme sur les plateaux de
télévision dans le débat public on n'a
jamais la même version n'a jamais les
précisions nécessaires et je constate en
effet qu'une réforme pour contestable et
qu'elle soit doit bénéficier d'un peu de
soutien et comme dans l'opinion un trou
dans l'opinion ou parmi les examens
concernés les corps concernés là je
constate que au niveau institutionnel on
a toutes les oppositions qui pour
diverses raisons sont contre la réforme
des retraites
le conseil d'état a étrillé l'étude
d'impact comme jamais il ne l'a fait
d'habitude il prend des gants ce n'a pas
été le cas cette fois ci il est allé
vraiment à la mitraillette
d'autre part quand je regarde dans le
fonctionnement de la démocratie c'est
aussi là que je vois que même le
patronat ne va pas au front pour
défendre les retraites et par exemple je
regardais les déclarations des syndicats
des cadres le gouvernement propose qu'au
delà de son ami l'euro on n'échappe
désormais aux cotisations aux fêtes et
patronales et salariales même les
syndicats des quatre ne souhaite pas en
fait cette proposition qui est faite par
le gouvernement
donc je me demande in fine et qui
soutient ses traits fins à part le
président de la rép les oppositions qui
est vent debout lydia guirous c'est
également qu'ils créent et critiquent le
fait qu'une conférence de financement
qui se tient alors que la réforme est
déjà janvier à riom les recettes
oui tout est incompréhensible en fait on
en a parlé depuis des semaines mais on
n'y comprend toujours rien le calendrier
est incompréhensible
il ya eu 18 mois de consultations ont
rien en est sorti personne n'est
d'accord avec cette réforme toutes les
oppositions sont vent debout
on a l'impression qu'ils veulent
piétiner le parlement en imposant un
débat qui est un très court il al'âge
hectares qui critiquent également
enfin voilà qui ne lâche toujours pas un
dernier sondage ne comprends pas cette
obstination en réalité dernier sondage
qui révèle que 50% des chefs
d'entreprise se disent favorables à
l'âge pivot mais la moitié se dit pas
favorable à l'âge pivot donc même là les
ddd 10 des dissonances jean paul huchon
comment faire vous allez trouver des
dissonances y compris avec le patronat
sur ce sujet mais aussi sur d'autres par
exemple peut on en parlera tout à
l'heure peut-être sur cette affaire des
de la possibilité pour les familles qui
ont perdu un enfant de faire le deuil
même le patronat
on a fini à plus de 6 kg il ya plus de
soutien hors franchement mais une
opération aussi bouleversante qui
concerne c'est pour ça que ça dure et
que c'est difficile
tous les français sont concernés c'est
fait c'est aberrant de vouloir sets
acharnés là dessus alors que en réalité
jamais les gens non élus macron pour
l'heure la retraite universel à tous à
tout le monde le sait c'est pas comme ça
que ça fait passer et ils font comme si
il avait un mandat du peuple pour faire
ça mais ne l'ont pas vous aviez vous
avoue qu'il y avait
et défendu en tout cas vos régimes de
retraite faso au ministre comment est ce
que vous sentez cette ouverture de
dialogue
est-ce qu'elle existe véritablement là
on n'a pas défendu on a essayé parce que
vous dit le départ anticipé nous l'avons
aujourd'hui on est sans lesquels les
coûts tout pas parce que c'est un peu la
question concilie à une écoute parce
qu'ils ont découvert comment
fonctionnait le régime de retraite
applique aux sapeurs pompiers voilà et
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on a
découvert découvert parce qu'en fait nos
interlocuteurs du cabinet delevoye ont
découvert que les sapeurs-pompiers
avaient un temps d'équivalence un temps
de travail équivalent alors beaucoup ne
le savent pas un tronc pieds quand ils
travaillent 24 heures on lui paye
seulement 16h ou 17h de travail donc le
problème des heures supplémentaires
comme il ya dans la police ça n'arrivera
pas chez les pompiers parce que notre
temps de travail n'est pas de 1607
heures comme tout le monde mais peut
aller jusqu'à 2 1956 et on est sur une
moyenne
les pompiers travaillent de 1200 heures
donc quand on nous dit que notre métier
il est dangereux
la reconnaissance de la nation ça
commencerait déjà aussi par là c'est de
sortir un décret de temps de travail
quand on a un temps travaillé comme tous
les autres fonctionnaires qu'on a un
temps de travail qui reconnaissait notre
travail de nuit parce que c'est
dangereux et qu'on doit être pour le
départ anticipé partir plus tôt parce
que on a des effets néfastes sur la
santé de notre métier est même déjà
qu'on commence par ne pas nous exposer
gratuitement
aujourd'hui ça nous rapporte rien à part
les maladies compagnie la mobilisation
se poursuit il y aura encore des
manifestations la semaine prochaine chez
les avocats également là aussi là ils ne
lâcheront rien sergio coronado moi je
fêterai et à la détermination et la
créativité d'ailleurs vous avez vu sur
les réseaux sociaux
tout n'est pas violent sera je voudrais
pas qu'on ait ce sentiment là souvent
les professions qui manifeste la
détermination et de créativité
d'imagination et je constate parce que
je suis ça avec beaucoup d'attention la
détermination des avocats en effet c'est
la première fois je vois bâtonnier
avocat toutes couleurs politiques
confondues race est un monde qui est
parfois très politisé où il ya des
joutes
une collègue l'audi team éditant une
colère inédite j'allais faire
j'allais faire une pique mais ma voisine
depuis rachida dati on n'avait pas vu
une telle mobilisation y nadine contre
mais n'ont pas paru c'était une pique et
elle était un peu déplacé ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est la première fois
qu'on constate en effet que devant une
mobilisation aussi massive d'une
profession comme celle des avocats
il y à un tel aveuglement une telle
volonté de croire qu au fond il avait
reçu mandat du peuple pour mener à bien
cette réforme c'est une caisse autonome
c'est une caisse qui n'est pas
déficitaire et on a le sentiment comme
le disent les avocats que l'état
désormais s'attaque à tous les bijoux de
famille de toutes les corporations de
tous les corps de métier pour finalement
abonder le budget limité d'entre eux lui
en tout cas absolument je voudrais qu'on
réagisse à ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine le salaire des cheminots
grévistes a fini dans les poches des
non-grévistes jean paul huchon des
primes pour ceux qui n'avaient pas fait
grève
et évidemment les heures de grève des
saletés des fiches de paye des cheminots
qu'est qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez il est sur cette affaire des
heures de grève payez pas payés etc
ça fait longtemps que on est revenu au
fait que quand on fait la grève on n'est
pas pays ça c'est clair donné les prix
aussi mais donner des primes à des gens
qui n'ont pas fait grève en plein combat
général sur ce sujet
c'est une provocation supplémentaire je
ne connais je connais bien le payant de
la sncf il n'a pas pu faire ça sans
avoir évoqué sa avec au moins son
ministre de tutelle pensée bas bien sûr
si on attendait le pédiatre été validées
alors au plus haut évidemment et c'est
une complètement pour les personnes qui
s'étaient pas fait grâce une provocation
de plus c'est légalement ils ceux qui
ont permis justement au service vous
avez raison ce n'était pas
nécessairement légal parce que le droit
de grève est un droit constitutionnel
donc subir une discrimination et ne pas
bénéficier de primes
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit très
légal et d'ailleurs les organisations
syndicales ont décidé de porter l
affaire
la prime est à l'isq devant le jeu de
l'employeur mais non mais non pas la
discrétion dans une entreprise comme la
sncf ou la ratp
je voudrais d'ailleurs tirer mon chapeau
à ces à ses agents qui ont fait que la
mobilisation des retraites a pris de
l'ampleur
même si ça a créé du désagrément parce
que les grèves elles ont affecté
essentiellement les salariés d'île de
france mais je trouve en effet qu'ils
ont eu du courage de la détermination et
qu'il le paye enfin je veux dire je ne
sais pas si vous avez vu céder des
fiches de paie qui arrive au mois de
janvier
tous les français ont les syndicats il
me semble notamment la cgt avait
communiqué là-dessus on sent qu'il y
avait eu des dons et donc qu'ils
financent éclats si vous commencez une
bien sûr c'est le temps de donner une
grimace
le climat social entre les grévistes et
les non grévistes au sein de
l'entreprise cesser délétère nom
l'indiqué ces cagnottes tout ça c'est
gentil mais c'est totalement mise à par
rapport à l'ampleur du truc
si les ccef prétend qu'elle a perdu je
sais pas vous voyez bien que ça n'a pas
de sens d'avancé les arguments comme ça
je ne comprends pas encore une fois la
sncf est une entreprise publique elle
n'a pas pu prendre ce type de
discussions sans en avoir référé ou
quelqu'un d'autre
quel message ça on voit alors de la part
du gouvernement puisque vous parlez de
c'est une espèce de 2,2 comme s'il y
avait une vengeance syfy que encourager
douala pour ne pas faire rentrer le
glisse voilà ces femmes et ça si vous
voulez c'était ça fait peut-être fait du
temps de factures mais ça ne se fait pas
honneur
on a souvent avec ce gouvernement ce
sentiment qu'il humilie qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à agir autrement que dans
l'humiliation et les catégories qui sont
concernés les prouve avec beaucoup
beaucoup de souffrances parfois c'est le
cas je disais tout à l'heure
parlant des avocats conti se mobilisent
et se sont mobilisés depuis plus d'un an
c'est pas la première fois qu'on voit
des robes
comme ça je t'ai devant un peu les
audiences solennelles ou ou des
représentants de l'état et la
concertation n'a jamais lieu en fait n'a
jamais lieu et qu'on vous entendez par
exemple madame bello béate et revenir
sur les ondes ou sur les pattes
télévision on est dans le déni absolu
c'est un régime universel tout le monde
doit y rentrer et il n'y a pas de
négociation possible c'est non
négociable
ceux qui souffrent ce dernier propose
toujours la maladresse ou de la
provocation avec le boudin et sur
beaucoup d'affaires de la répétition
donne peut-être la réponse
voilà en tout cas les lycéens eux aussi
ont souffert d'avoir fait grève en
puisque certains n'ont pas pu entrer
lors d'une séance de rattrapage
d'histoire-géo ça se passe ça s'est
passé à la rochelle ils ont fait grève
ils ont bloqué le lycée
du coup ils n'ont pas pu rentrer lors de
cette séance de rattrapage cette semaine
réaction peut-être xavier bois quand on
interdit à des lycéens qu'ils ont qui
ont bloqué un lycée de de pouvoir
assister à la séance de rattrapage alors
leurs réactions déjà 500 voix pas un
beau message de notre pays et est des
enfants c'est tuer des enfants elle n
est pas la même mais non mais c'est pas
si inquiétant quand même parce que tout
à l'heure récompenser les non grévistes
aujourd'hui enfin maintenant sur les
lycéens dire ben voila j'ai que vous
avez voulu faire grève la prochaine fois
c'est pas un bon message ça renvoie des
périodes assez sombre quand même de
l'histoire de france
ça me fait penser à ça c'est une
réaction tout de suite à chaud je pense
qu'effectivement le système de
revaloriser un salariés non grévistes ne
pas être légal il ya déjà dédé des
jugements dans ce sens là où on fait
venir des intérimaires ou des gens pour
remplacer les grévistes n'est pas
autorisé devant la justice mais voilà
même le bénévolat c'est pas autorisé
pour un pc crise parce qu'on n'en remets
un principe constitutionnel quand même
de n'empêchait la grève là aussi est ce
que c'est c'est pas légal sergio
coronado d'interdire à un lycéen de
de 6 à une épreuve importante en plus
pour son avenir
bah je crois que s'en prendre à des
lycéens qui ont fait preuve d'esprit de
citoyenneté moi je ne suis pas père de
famille mais je mon frère aller par
exemple est content
ses enfants lui raconte des choses qui
relèvent de la politique de la vie
publique
ils donnaient plutôt fier donc de punir
à 6 d'hélicéa mais c'est une règle quasi
générale depuis l'élection des manuels
vaincrons rappelez vous les images
choquantes de s'est laissé aller à
genoux les mains derrière le dos ou là
dernièrement des lycéens du 20e
arrondissement également qu'ils
finissent en garde à vue pendant 24
heures moi je ne dis pas que tout doit
être autorisée mais à quoi sert ces
mesures qui sont punitive humiliante
pour des jeunes gens qui découvrent en
fait l'engagement le débat public la
mobilisation sociale
on a l'impression en effet qu'on veut
punir humilier en permanence et on
revient à ce qui caractérise finalement
cette méthode odieuse gouverner on leur
reproche à bloquer le lycée pas avant de
remplacer leur est propre c'est ça il ya
une fois il ya une prise d'otages c'est
se passe dans les lycées ça se passe
dans les universités aussi il faut être
faut aussi comprendre leurs examens et
qui veut y voilà et je pense que parfois
il faut rappeler aussi les règles et le
respect des autres
oui et notamment sur les mots parce que
utiliser le terme de prise d'otages sur
un débrayage de lycée ou d'université
vous m'excuserez mais ça fera notre
dépasser l'heure du coup de gueule après
cette option si vous voulez
et pour vous jean paul huchon un coup de
gueule contre le rejet de l'allongement
du congé d'un salarié venant de perdre
un enfant
si j'ai bien compris le peur de la vue
qu'a fait savoir par un collaborateur
c'est pas lui qui l'a fait directement
qu'il fallait faire preuve d'un peu
d'humanité dans gouverne le président a
recadré effectivement et si vous vous
rendez compte où on en est vous perdez
un enfant c'est là votre vie qui
s'effondre d'un seul coup et il faut un
peu de temps il faut un petit délai pour
venir à bout de ces situations tragiques
et le faire comme ça et le faire gérer
par le gouvernement par le ministre la
ministre qui s'est engagé en même temps
alors à l'assemblée ça chahute est un
peu bien sûr mais c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment inadmissible
ces lignes mannix et une proposition les
centristes qui voulait augmenter à 12
jours au lieu de cinq aujourd'hui et ça
a été retoqué par la majorité ont
souhaité qu'on s'était donc par une
députée et cesser votre coup violent
également les diagonales de même ce gain
voilà on se réunit là-dessus trouvé ça
indécent et fashion
c'était soutenu par par les républicains
et puis voir la république en marche ne
pas voter pour cet allongement du congé
à cause de deuil quand on perd un enfant
enfin y'a pas plus dramatiques comme
situation à ce compte est ce qu on se
relève de savoir si c'est ça que ce
n'est pas besoin de maîtrise de 2,2 sur
les bleus mais méconnu il énonce ont
réagi pour dire qu évidemment ils sont
favorables à cela et qui il faut donner
le temps à la personne de se relever de
cette épreuve donc le medef est quand
même plus sensible que les députés de la
république en marche il faut que le
président de la république intervienne
pour dur fait quand même preuve
d'humanité la ya une forme de
déconnexion et demande de sensibilité
d'humanité qui fait parfois un peu froid
dans le dos quand même parce que jean
paul huchon
ils sont là ils ont vraiment fait la
totale fidjien parce que quand on sait
que laurence parisot qui n'est pas
totalement n'importe qui et que le
président du medef
bézieux a dit attendez c'est pas ça qui
va mettre les entreprises en perte
compétitivité avant les cheminées fou de
dire des choses comme ça effet saisi ses
députés de ils ont compris ils sont
totalement à côté de lui on devrait
quand même est alerté compte l'ensemble
des oppositions et là c'était le cas sur
cette proposition de rebalancement il y
avait le filet social master les
républicains mais il y avait déjà eu
cette unanimité des oppositions sur la
privatisation d'atp ça n'avait pas fait
bouger d'un iota sur gouvernement à un
moment donné on se dit n'a rien de leur
fille at il pour prendre en compte les
opposition unanime ou majoritaires dans
le pays pour en tenir compte
on verra l'avenir nous le dira merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci jean paul
huchon merci didier rous pour votre
contribution apolit my merci xavier bois
et merci sergio coronado rendu à nos
questions sur arte france c'est la fin
de police mag rester avec nous
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]